there's really an element too of your
job where it's just people where you
there's moments where you're really
involved in the magic of life
yes that's awesome man it's a lot of fun
i bet that's really awesome has there
been anybody that's come to see you
that's kind of been on their way out of
the world you know that's leaving life
and they wanted to come see santa one
more time
yes it's not so much
older people but it is
parents who bring their child who has a
terminal illness
and i always have a special bell
that i give to children like that and
about eight years ago i had given one to
this little
girl she had spina bifida and some other
problems going on
in about uh this was early in the season
and probably about a week or 10 days
later
the mom comes back and she's just
bawling in tears and then i realize who
she was
and she came back to tell me that her
child had died
and she buried her child with that bell
that i had given them
yeah it's interesting uh i think people
you you know they look to santa
i think as like a symbol of like hope
and
oh yeah love you know a symbol of magic
you know a symbol of what else uh could
be out there that we don't know
from time to time usually five or six
times a year
i will have a child come to me and tell
me santa
i don't want you to bring me anything
this year
i want my friend or my cousin or my mom
or my dad to get
a special christmas is that pretty
remarkable when you see that when a kid
asks yeah
and here's what i do first of all
if you think about children most
children are takers
they take stuff they want stuff given to
them oh yeah
there are very very few children that
are what i call
giver children they want to give to
other people
they don't want something for themselves
so when i when
that child when i see that child
and we're done with the visit i bring
the parents in
or the parent if there's only one that
came with them and i'll say do you know
what your child your little girl your
little boy asked me for
and they'll say no and i said i'll then
tell them the story of what the child
asked me for
in about half the time the parents will
know that they have a
that child's a giver child wow about the
other half of the time
the parents had no idea but they're
thrilled
that their child is that way
and i said and i said and that's when i
make the
the gift of the bell to the child i have
the parent and the child there and i'm
explaining to them what's
what's transpired and i'll tell the
child that every time you ring that bell
i'll be thinking about you oh i love
that yeah
you know there's something special about
just being that uh it's almost to get
like you're like a middleman for um
yeah it's like you're like a middle man
for some of the joy that's out in the
world
right it must feel pretty interesting
sometimes it is
it's it's a it's a lot of responsibility
but it's uh
gratefully accepted responsibility amen
yeah yeah i bet to just to have to be
able to be like at work and have a few
moments like that
some people don't have moments like that
in their job their entire lives you know
so to be able to have that and then also
uh not only just like take it and
be like this is what i'm doing but take
it and just act the part of
being kind of just part of the current
of whatever that good energy is and i've
had children as well as adults
that ask me to pray with them and i will
pray with them
right there right there on the set
before they leave amen
i'm just sitting on your front porch
wondering how could i be
so far from my home
and my mind is somewhere else but when i
find it i'll patch up where it's been